ils aviez moreau merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer deux quel type d'entraînement
aérien dénoncées par la russie
parlant nous bien en fait ce sont peut
être différent récemment il n'y a eu à
la frontière norvégienne
trois bombardiers b-52 et vous avez eu
également des des avions de
reconnaissance on en a vu beaucoup en
mer noire est c'est fait c'est assez
classique je dirais dans une perspective
de guerre froide on avait on a connu
beaucoup ça pendant la guerre froide les
l'épisode le plus le plus connu c'était
un avis un avion espion le u2 en 1960
qui avait été abattu d'ailleurs par là
par l'adc la soviétique donc cette on
est de manière générale je dirais on est
dans la tentative et de justification
existentielle de l'otan à un moment où
son existence justement est remise en
question
d'une part parce que eh bien par exemple
vous avez la grèce et la turquie qui
sont deux pays de l'otan qui sont sur le
point de s'affronter
d'autre part parce que vous avez des
critiques au sein des membres les plus
importants de l'otan c'est le cas de la
france qui puisque man mal qu'on a dit
que l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale est également vous avez la
question du transfert des troupes
allemandes des troupes américaines dans
l'allemagne vers la pologne
donc il s'agit de trouver une
justification à l'existence de l'otan et
donc et bien l'existence de l'otan sa
justification à la base c'est de faire
la guerre à la russie et jusqu'en 2014
comme l'a souligné le ministre de la
défense monsieur choïgou l'otan
cherchait sa justification en 2013 les
deux justifications de l'otan c'était la
lutte contre la piraterie au large des
côtes africaines et la lutte contre le
trafic d'êtres humains
ça me fait beaucoup rire et la guerre
civile ukrainienne à donner à l'otan une
nouvelle justification et c'est à dire
est revenu à ça à sa destination
initiale qui est de tenir tête à la
russie on voit d'ailleurs par exemple au
secrétaire général de l'otan stoltenberg
qui prend des positions très fermes
vis-à-vis de la russie dans le cadre de
la 2
d'empoisonnement supposé de d'alexa une
avanie alors le ministre russe de la
défense a notamment déclaré que si une
majorité de pays avaient accepté le fait
qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul périmètre du
monde à l'apparition d'un autre pôle de
contre-pouvoir ne pouvait que leur
déplaire comment est-ce que vous
analysez cette déclaration en fait il
faut considérer que l'otan est davantage
une structure politique aujourd'hui
qu'une structure militaire puisque tout
le monde sait bien que la russie ne va
pas envahir les pays bas 2 va envahir la
pologne
d'ailleurs la russie a construit des
ports sur la baltique pour ne plus avoir
utilisé les ports des pays bas donc ils
ne vont pas une révolte il va pas
envahir des pays dont il essaie
justement de ce2 ce2 se débarrasser
comme comme partenaire économique ça
n'aurait pas de sens en revanche le
l'otan est un moyen d'unir politiquement
la plupart des pays d'europe derrière le
leadership américain et donc
effectivement le dans ce cas le ministre
de la défense russe a raison c'est à
dire qu'il ya une une tension une besoin
un besoin de maintenir l'unité derrière
washington et donc il faut inventer un
conflit potentiel tout en sachant qu'en
une fois que l on ne fait pas la guerre
entre puissances nucléaires
donc ni les états unis ni la russie ni
la france ni l'angleterre ne vont se
faire la guerre donc ça c'est la
justification dont le but est avant tout
politique
alors on vous entend aujourd'hui les
relations entre la russie et l'otan d'un
point de vue politique mais justement
elles sont très mauvaises elles sont
très mauvaises depuis 2014
et puis là comme je viens de le dire
notamment dans le cadre de la sphère de
la ferme à manille le secrétaire général
de l'otan stoltenberg et qui pourtant à
l'époque où il était tête du
gouvernement suédois s'est très bien
entendu avec avec avec medvedev donc
effectivement ce n'est pas ce c'est
quelqu'un qui sait pertinemment qu'on
peut s'entendre avec la russie cependant
il n'est pas dans l'intérêt des dés de
l'otan que les choses se passent bien
que le fascinant l'otan va disparaître
si jamais on se pose vraiment la
question à quoi sert l'otan l'otan ne
sert à rien puisque la russie n'est plus
une menace et a autre chose à faire que
de rendre une fois d'envahir les pays
baltes ou ou la pologne le seul pays
dans laquelle avec laquelle la russie
pour être en guerre c'est ça serait
l'ukraine puisque le référendum a
provoqué la réunification de la crimée
avec la russie et en soit le seul pays
qui pourraient déclarer la guerre à la
russie c'est le cred mais l'ukraine ne
fait pas partie de l'otan je dirais même
si la russie décidé d'envahir d'envahir
l'ukraine l'otan devrait pas intervenir
une intérieure devrait de toute manière
pas du coup ces manoeuvres militaires de
l'otan à proximité des frontières russes
elle risque de continuer dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent
je pense je pense qu'on est tout tout au
début d'un cycle 2 de tension de montée
en tension contre la russie il faudrait
aussi qu'ils font peut-être remettre ça
dans le contexte des élections
américaines et notamment puisque je
crois que c'est aujourd'hui
donald trump a dénoncé le bellicisme du
pentagone en disant qu'il était apprécié
par les soldats mais pas parler les
officiers généraux qui eux souhaitent
faire la guerre et il s'est vanté d'être
le seul à ne pas avoir fait la guerre
elle pas recommencer de guerre les
présidents des états unis depuis
longtemps donc il ya peut être aussi une
volonté de la part du pentagone de
provoquer une tension vis-à-vis de la
russie pour donner des arguments aux
anti russe dans le cadre de la campagne
américaine
merci beaucoup et xavier
moreau pour votre analyse je rappelle
que vous êtes directeur de strates paul